(upbeat music)
(steam hisses)
♪ Oh oh oh oh ♪
You know, I live for a beauty tip.
So here's one for you,
hopefully you'll love.
Hey Drew, it's Chris Appleton.
And today I'm gonna show you
how to create a messy bun
in a few simple steps.
All you're gonna need is a hairbrush,
a couple of pins,
and I love to use
the COLORWOW Style on Steroids texturizing spray.
When you're creating a messy bun
the key is to keep a lot of texture in the hair.
It increases the diameter of the hair
and gives you a lot of volume.
Then what you wanna do is work the hair up.
Now, what I like to do
is just keep a couple of pieces down at the front
and then using my fingers,
just pull the hair up into a high ponytail.
Now, the key for you guys, creating this at home
is to follow your cheek bone.
That's the perfect place for you to land your ponytail.
Then we're gonna take our elastic
and tie the hair up high.
Now, remember when you're doing this
you wanna make sure you almost go a little bit higher
than what you want,
just 'cause naturally when you're tying your hair high
it always tends to fall a little bit lower.
I like to then just take my brush
and all we're gonna do
is take the bun
and just tease it a little bit.
So we have a little bit more volume.
I have a couple of pins.
All you wanna do is twist the hair
and wrap it around in a circular motion,
taking the very ends
and just tucking them underneath.
Then what I like to do,
once you get the position right,
is just pin it in place.
Or like I say, you need just a couple of pins.
So we'll put one on this side,
one this side,
and that should be held in place.
A little bit closer
you can see there's nice texture in there.
It's not too neat.
So don't start getting anything that's too perfect.
This is your pin you wanna use.
I'm just taking a large pin
and just anchoring it right at the base of the bun,
just on both sides here.
But at this point, all you wanna do
is just go in and refine the edges.
I like to use my fingers.
If there's any like real lumps and bumps
I'll just take my pin and just pin it into place,
just so you can kind of really tidy up the edges.
And then see any little flyaway hairs like this,
I like to then use the Style on Steroids, texturizing spray
just to help give me a bit more volume and hold.
I don't think you need hair spray on this
because it should be light and airy
and have that really voluminous finish.
I can't wait to try that.
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh oh oh oh ♪